j'aurais de cabillaud la lys faisons
excellemment bien son travail
elle aime toujours disponible toujours
prêt chaque fois que vous appeler pour
vous on fait l'ouverture en fonction de
l'épaisseur des avions ça sur le plan
mécanique sous d'autres d'autres comités
donc de la charge de président il était
toujours présent
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui car il sait
que je peux dire de lui cède un point et
qu'on ne croise pas prévu que de valeur
une de 13 et votre train d'enquêter
aussi récompensé honoré par la menace
qu'est ce que vous vouliez sans lui à
travers cette médaille moi je dis que 87
médailles dont il s'agit donc du comité
des médaillés de la jeunesse et des
sports de l'engagement associatif et
camille avait la médaille d'argent alors
c'est juste après c'est la médaille d'or
je crois que kabylie a eu 7 7 7
médailles les deux bronze et argent
parce que il a été un militant qui a
toujours joué même peut-être pas dans le
domaine associatif mais pour la
promotion de tous les sports il avait
une culture de ce sport a beau la vie
fondamentale énorme c'est mieux pour qui
j'ai beaucoup de respect nous avions
rendez vous après le carnaval pour faire
un point sur la situation actuelle du
sport automobile a vanté les qualités de
regards qui l'avait jamais qu'il se sait
jamais d'avoir des idées plein la tête
et je suis sûr qu'il est parti et la
houle et qui a tellement d'idées qu'il
avait qui l'ont aimé concrétiser des
projets qu'ils ont aimé concrétiser qui
soit je suis vraiment déçu de voir la
preuve est évidente et ça me fait une
bonne pêche